Weltweit wird ein Fünftel der Energie für
Licht gebraucht - bei uns sind das meistens
LED-Lampen, die sehr viel Licht - und das
mit wenig Strom - produzieren. Doch es kommen
mittlerweile immer mehr Studien auf den Tisch,
die LED-Licht als große Gefahr für unsere
Augen identifizieren! Und genau deswegen seid
ihr auch auf das Thema aufmerksam geworden
und habt es Euch bei Whats App als Video gewünscht.
Tadaaa, hier ist es! Was also genau das Problem
an LED-Lampen ist und wie wir das Risiko für
unsere Gesundheit senken können - das alles
und noch viel mehr, bekommt ihr jetzt in Clixoom
Science & Fiction, herzlich willkommen.
Dank Eurer Augen könnt ihr mich und dieses
Video hier jetzt sehen. Die Augen sind tatsächlich
unser zentrales Sinnesorgan: Bis zu 80 Prozent
aller Infos aus der Umwelt nehmen wir dank
ihnen wahr. Unsere Augen haben also jede Menge
zu tun: Permanent gucken wir auf Laptops,
Smartphone oder Fernseher und genau das könnte
ziemlich unangenehme Folgen für uns haben.
Denn zur Hintergrundbeleuchtung in Tablets
und Co sind meistens Leuchdioden, also LED,
zur Hintergrundbeleuchtung eingebaut. Sie
verbrauchen deutlich weniger Energie als klassische
Glühbirnen und werden so mittlerweile nicht
nur in Bildschirmen, sondern auch in Lampen,
Scheinwerfern und Werbeplakaten eingesetzt.
Konkret produzieren die LED-Lampen blaues
und gelbes Licht, um am Ende das gewünscht
weiße Licht zu erhalten. Doch mittlerweile
mehren sich die Anzeichen, dass das enthaltene
blaue Licht sehr schädlich für unsere Augen
sein könnte. Im Gegensatz zum Spektrum des
Sonnenlichts, das gleichmäßig über den
gesamten Wellenlängenbereich verteilt ist,
zeigt das Spektrum von LED eine Spitze bei
400 bis 480 Nanometer. Dieses Licht ist besonders
energiereich und kommt fast ungefiltert durch
das Auge auf die Netzhaut. Denn anders als
das UV-Licht wird es NICHT im vorderen Augenbereich
absorbiert. So soll es starke Schäden an
Netzhaut und Sehzellen hervorrufen. Konkret
entsteht fotooxidativer Stress: Sauerstoffradikale
entstehen, die Proteine und Lipide schädigen
und dann zum Tod der Sehzellen führen können.
Und das ist irreversibel: Abgestorbene Sehzellen
werden nicht mehr ersetzt und das Sehvermögen
nimmt Stück für Stück ab. Zudem schädigt
LED-Licht wohl auch die Pigmentzellen der
Netzhaut. Alterungsprozesse werden beschleunigt,
vermehrt Abfallstoffe gebildet und genau das
schädigt dann wiederum die Sehzellen.
Wie viel blaues Licht notwendig ist, um diese
Worst Case-Schäden zu verursachen, wissen
Forschungsteams allerdings noch nicht ganz
genau..Hinweise dazu liefert allerdings eine
Studie aus Frankreich: Hierbei wurde untersucht,
welche Auswirkungen die verschiedenen Lichtarten
auf unsere Augen haben können.Das Ganze wurde
an Ratten getestet, von denen jeweils eine
Gruppe Licht aus Leuchtröhren, herkömmlichen
Glühbirnen und LED-Licht ausgesetzt wurde.
Alle Lichtquellen führten bei einer hohen
Intensität von 6000 Lux zu Entzündungen,
die am Ende zum Absterben der Sehzellen führten.
Bei 500 Lux, also einer deutlich geringeren
Lichtintensität, dagegen, wurde die Netzhaut
der Tiere nur durch das LED-Licht beeinträchtigt.
Das alles sind die Ergebnisse aus Tierversuchen
- Langzeitversuche an Menschen gibt es noch
nicht.
Doch auch schon derzeit kommen einige Faktoren
zusammen: Mehr LEDs werden in den verschiedenen
Bereichen des Lebens eingesetzt und wir nutzen
sie intensiver als früher. Dazu kommt die
besondere spektrale Lichtzusammensetzung,
für die unsere Augen besonders anfällig
sind. Nicht zuletzt wird die Lichtintensität
von LED-Lampen durch eine EU-Norm gerecht.
Und es gibt einige Aspekte, die jeder selbst
beachten kann, um das Risiko von Augenschäden
zu senken. Gefährlicher als das warm-weiße
LED-Licht ist das kalt-weiße Licht. Zudem
kann man das Licht von Monitoren in einen
gelblicheren Bereich umstellen und so seine
Augen schonen. Unbedingt vermeiden sollte
man es, direkt in helle LED-Quellen hineinzuschauen,
beispielsweise kann man beim Fernseh-Gucken
lieber noch eine weitere Lichtquelle im Raum
dazu einschalten.